oh
[Applaudissements]
joyeux vendre des fous cher employés de
we love toys on se fait une crête pas la
fermeture
de la caisse ce soir ils le mangent mis
une seconde je m'appelle émettent de
dieu travailler dans les antres faut
qu'un jour des plus dangereux pour un
vendeur que le jour du vendredi foule
o2 quoi est-ce qu on raffole des jouets
c'est une affaire qui marche et tout le
monde soit 2
je vous remercie et bonnes fêtes
[Musique]
mais quoi je t'assure que j'ai un truc
qui cloche avec les clients
cette fois on doit faire quelque chose
ça fait pas une heure qu on a ouvert nos
portes et on vire le client plein
vendredi fou
quoi c'était le stagiaire
donc ça veut dire qu'on leur paie on va
devoir se battre
[Applaudissements]
je dirais que la situation ne peut pas
et il
déteste je suis le seul à trouver ça
drôle
j'étais sûr de parcourir
est classé dans le ventre des fous et
pour vos pairs vue des jeux qui comptent
à mourir tant d'encre rouge pâle
stagiaires
c'est mal le star qu'ils ont fait
les jeunes taureaux avec médor
c'est très bas police a dit que soit le
temps
là
ça
[Musique]
cela n'était pas en promotion respectifs